welcome back to new rock stars news
today we're gonna be talking about
spider-man far from home when we've got
some set picks a new suit reveal and
we'll also be touching on venom deleted
scenes in daredevil season 3 is stock
and bore what else are we what else is
going on there's the thing that I'm
super excited about you guys know I love
horror is that the new Halloween movie
came out except we're not covering it in
this episode because we have a bunch of
other videos we have a video Derek just
shot and then we have another breakdown
coming that's all next week but also
Halloween quick reminder about our
mashup costume contest do ideas you
match them together like mashing
potatoes you put them together that's
not works send us a picture of yourself
in a mashup Halloween costume on any of
our social accounts or Twitter Instagram
bumble and buy this Wednesday the 24th
and we're gonna post our top 5 faves on
Instagram and our number 1 winner will
be on next week's show we're flying you
out baby not a picture of you but you'll
still be in the show and we'll still
pretend that you're here with us yeah
jump on that we'd love to see what you
guys come up with another I'm Erik Bosse
joining me today at the table are Sam
Bosch Vermont Garrett and Phillip Malina
yeehaw
welcome back guys let's get started with
our top story so spider-man far from
home has officially wrapped filming
according to Tom Hollands Instagram now
this movie comes out next summer July
5th which is the same weekend at
spider-man homecoming was released in
2017 so if we assume the marketing
strategy will be similar we might have
to wait till December to see our first
trailer dependents appreciate emerging
the spider movie with an Avengers movie
so we might see a spider-man homecoming
trailer before we see Avengers 4 that
would be crazy fun either way until then
let's overanalyze some set pics this is
all we got but we get so much out of
these kind of slow news week here we're
doing our best to talk about some great
team 5:21 he's a hundred zone adult now
yeah this suit I just look at his dick
80% a dolt
along with the mysterious shots yeah
you'd be feeling like you're literally
naked actually Sammy we had a flash
costume all the time basic basically it
is she doesn't get you take it off
infinity fan mm next time I do that show
I'm gonna be wearing something else
along with that spent spider-man costume
mysterious shots a wild bag we're also
getting some glimpses of for potential
spider-man suits in this movie so along
with the shots and spider-man of the
spider-man homecoming version of the
suit we got a glimpse of an all-black
stealth perhaps version of the suit
which was apparently used in some of the
European scenes we've heard European Tom
Holland filming motion capture which
could mean a reappearance of the iron
spider suit from of interest infinity
war um and now we've got this red and
black one that Tom Holland wore on Jimmy
Kimmel last night and some are saying
it's the MCU stake on the superior
spider-man suit here you can see him
with MJ's rocket oh she is rocking a
joan of arc shirt her shirts are always
great all the shirts and these
spider-man movies are on point Joan of
Arc or Joan of Arcadia I was a big fan
why do you think there are so many suits
does the airline loses luggage or having
different missions that you wrote or
write you need like each look like this
is my Milan
someone who sets him up with the coolest
stuff all the time and only has to do is
save the world it is a closetful Nick
Fury is a sugar daddy is that an
appropriate that's probably your saying
I think Tony Stark was but I guess he's
gonna upgrade now and also somebody said
that on the one of the stealth suits you
can kind of see like a little shield
logo or something yeah right there you
can see it on his on the upper right
there very much I mean I think in that
photo it's just a little bit cold mm-hmm
you know he's wearing like I would say a
second skin there so he just needs to
rug up a little bit more oh yeah I
thought you were trying to explain why
we can't see you the man also there was
that say that came out that said
spider-man still like outperforms all
toy sales for any character everything
behind yeah it's like four times what
all Avengers toys make so it's like that
is the most recognizable fictional
character after Jesus I think I like
this idea the shield because to me it
creates this idea of what if spider-man
is like being a contractor for shield
and far from home yeah it's gonna be
r-rated no I yeah like maybe that's why
he's going he's having to like going
these missions for a field trip but
every time he's there he gets a call
from Nick Fury like while you're there
in Venice would you mind swinging
through the Grand Canal and and fixing
this it's like come on wait you just
said imagine if you got webbed through
the face and they're like wait we can't
find his brain oh don't oh my god it's
just wept of the wall like you want your
r-rated movies don't you
it's like I told you he's a minute I
think that's the most likely place I'd
be curious to see the iron spider suit
because it's kind of hard after you'd go
to iron spider in infinity war it's the
coolest version of Spider Man suit dude
is that step down after that it's like
why would you not go why would you go to
a stealth version other than self got it
I know an expert you need to charge it
too much yeah you go back to the flip
phone basically baby saw it sidenote tom
hollander the next Bond baby buns baby
mind like boss baby spin-off baby I'm in
yeah fully an adult baby alright let's
do it yeah let's go mind together
different suits and hopefully it would
be really cool if we only saw a trailer
for spider-man far from home before we
see anything for Avengers 4 right that'd
be insane of Marvel to do that but we're
all gonna see Avengers 4 anyway all they
need to do is put a release date and
then let the rest of us dig through this
fake leaked trailer that has been making
the rounds take that video out watch it
yeah it's pretty bad it's a thing yeah
it's too fanservice see but yeah let us
know what you think it's gonna be coming
from far from home but for now let us
move on to this week's a trivia question
oh and our fancy I still we got the box
okay so we're just going back to it I
mean this is the steaks steaks clear
steaks not like thick meaty steaks I
want some crystal steaks kingdom of the
crystal steaks so yeah what's gonna
happen here as always the loser will
have to pull from the gif of shame box
but everyone are we ready for the
question question is in Spider Man's
first appearance in 1962 he uses his
newfound abilities to win $100 by
fighting a wrestler what is the
wrestlers name alright all the answers
are here in the bin and we'll reveal the
answer at the end of the video get Shane
coming your way
but let's move on to some other news
this week now that most comic geeks have
probably seen venom you don't have an
excuse if you haven't people have
started to speculate about some of the
potential deleted scenes a lot of
have heard about these 30 to 40 minutes
at Tom Hardy reference as his favorite
that were ripped out of the film I said
that there are 30 40 minutes of worth of
scenes that just aren't in this movie
and they also reference that they could
be about Mad puppeteering scenes and
dark comedy scenes so we're just gonna
dig into that for you and take some
guesses
I mean if it's his favorite 30 to 40
minutes right I imagine it's 30 to 40
minutes that had Tom Hardy be physical
lorne he got to kind of like show when
he could make like you know he wasn't
just a superhero he was a super actor
mm-hmm you're probably right yeah it
probably is like he's doing things that
were like difficult to portray that he's
like not doing it but at the same time
he is doing it maybe like robbed people
or something committed I don't know if I
could have used more lobster eating
scenes in the movie I thought the one in
the restaurant was fine it was one of
the highlights of the movie and another
one unless they heightened it in some
way I don't think they need to hide him
but what I did need was more like of
understanding the relationship between
Eddie Brock and venom as characters and
why they decide to want to work together
because the whole you know dynamic of
the movie is that these are like an odd
couple they shouldn't want to work
together so by the end of the second act
we should learn what clicks like why why
do they fall in love basically and it
would that part was missing I wonder if
some of the 30 or 40 minutes were like
that kind of discovery and that that
journey that they going together and
maybe they go on a rescue mission or
something and every website you wouldn't
want that to be comedic you're saying
like you like don't have more comedy add
more I think if it was comedic in nature
but if it was just like something if I'm
right in a movie there's some things
you're put in there just for the gag
like if you imagine like that scene in
the in the dinner restaurant and scene
with the lobster that was just like a
sketch inserted in the movie like the
you know the writers were like okay
something funny needs to happen a or
that shows Tom Hardy in this dilemma I
don't know if I need another one of the
scenes because that check that box for
me but we needed some like basic story
scenes of like showing how the
characters form their relationship
together and why Eddie Brock is an
essential host for a venom to possess
rather than just like you know a
disposable thing like why is that he
brought like the perfect match yeah like
a weapon they should explore why he
doesn't come out more like why is he
eating him from the inside and it's not
like bothering him or why doesn't he
come out because like he can't be
stopped in any way so why doesn't he
just we ready all the time and like not
let Eddie make any decision whatsoever
they never explore that or make any kind
of important decision about that it's
just happening because we know the
character is supposed to be that way and
normal audiences it doesn't matter so I
don't know maybe something exploring
that like why why is it important
whatsoever that Eddie has a say yeah the
moral side of it all I just keep
thinking about upgrade where poor man's
Tom Hardy like that was like the same
sort of thing but it's like the
technology was taking over him but it's
like why they worked together yeah yeah
wait did address those things yeah
really well I liked that maybe guys all
right well let us know what you guys
think but I'm fine with the way it was
see the blu-ray see if there's a super
character I can't control myself I'll
watch the extra 40 minutes I'll let you
guys know Oh
before that I was checking out daredevil
season 3 because that drunk last night
before we started recording and so I
watched it this morning before I came in
and my thoughts on it it's great it's
the most solid out of all these Netflix
shows I do like Jessica Jones I like
Luke Cage but like the daredevil seasons
have always been just I become more
invested quicker in them and I it was
nice getting back into this totally
forgot what happened in defenders
honestly like going into this I'm like
where is that character right now I'm
like oh yeah so we're pickup lot it's a
lot so they pick up right from there and
I think one of the benefits from this is
the new genre showrunner is really
focusing on like what his abilities are
if he's going through trauma he's
healing from something what can ER can't
he do and what does he have to do to
like kind of recover from that or can he
recover from that so there's a lot of
benefits there and I'm excited to see
what they do with the side characters
because they're kind of on their own
from what matt murdock is doing at least
in the beginning of the season I've only
watched one episode but so far I'm very
happy with it are you guys gonna be
watching it I know nervous about
investing into the like so I know we're
gonna talk a little more about it but
iron fist getting canceled yeah and then
so Disney's new service the rumor on
street if you guys have heard this is
it's gonna launch in q1 so somewhere
between January and March of 2019 if it
does like are we getting more daredevil
I don't know I get like nervous about
just like investing even
further down this road and they're just
being that much more upset when they're
like nevermind we're not gonna do
anything more there and just ending
abruptly or something mm-hmm I would say
if you enjoy enough of what daredevil
has done already it's cool to see where
these characters go and it's not it
after the defenders I don't know if you
watched Jessica Jones Luke Cage or even
iron fist they kind of didn't
acknowledge me met each other anymore
they would bring them in for like a
special crossover episode we're like in
Luke Cage iron Tristan and Luke would
team up and that was actually really
cool and in season two of iron fists you
had misty coming over more and they had
daughters of the Dragon which is really
interesting but we'll talk about iron
fist in a second I recommend checking
out are you gonna check out yeah I might
give it a shot but it's like we have to
cover a lot you know I feel like I'm
watching a lot of different things right
now and but I do wanna check out because
they think daredevil is like the my
personal favorite of like the I like
Luke Cage a lot and I like Jessica Jones
a lot but daredevil that's like the
first one I kind of have more attachment
to the character a bit more of it yeah
it's I think the hard part with the
these crossovers is each show is so
totally different you know and that's
one thing they've done really job a good
job of is creating the worlds even
though they're all they all take place
within the same six blocks of Hell's
Kitchen New York oh well not Harlem I
guess Luke Cage but hell's kitchen's
very small neighborhood so they make
each feel like its own universe and I
think it's really good job by each of
those showrunners
but the extended universe of it which is
what Marvel Comics it's really their
strong suit despite certain videos that
went the rounds this week saying like
expanded the universe mean bad
storytelling but I think that is what
Marvel comics is the reason it's popular
and I think that's why the MCU one of
the reasons has been such a success and
one of the reason you feel investment
and installment to installment and I and
I don't really feel that with the shows
that I have to be really really excited
about this particular season and these
themes and the music and whatever each
show has question I mean I personally
think the CW is doing a better job with
crossovers and pop and ain't just works
and it's like at a good time do you
think that maybe Netflix is biggest
problem here is that you can binge them
all and it's not weekly and episode akin
that in that way it's that's a good
question because the CW keeps adding
shows and people keep watching them
because they keep getting multiple
seasons so I can't say that they're not
they're doing
too much maybe that might be it because
it's easier to maybe it that on that
schedule of like one episode a day
instead of getting 13 at once you're
like I can't do that I haven't finished
maniac because it's like 10 episodes
like hey look it also I feel the
opposite way where the CW shows like
burned me out like I had to brief
everyone for anything there every night
of the week you miss one then it's like
oh gosh but yeah especially like they're
referencing each other and stuff so yeah
I don't know I don't know which ways
better it's also tough because Netflix
doesn't release its number so we don't
even know if they're getting anything
similar to the CW shows or not it's a
fascinating question and I think it's
you know I'm sure everyone at HBO and
all these other streaming services and
Netflix
they're wondering constantly like is it
his appointment is there something to be
said for appointment television where
it's like Tuesday nights a day I will be
watching I will be here and watch this
or I'll watch it later on DVR or
something but we've got a whole week to
one yeah one episode yeah yeah yeah you
got plenty of time and you don't there
isn't a time limit on these but you
talked about numbers being released and
a big surprise last year that Ironfist
got announced to get season two because
apparently when it came out it was like
one of the most popular shows at least
the first episode that Netflix ever had
but after season two iron fist has been
canceled that's the biggest thing ever
forever I don't know what happened but I
probably said something stupid I
couldn't pull cheers and cheers the iron
fist more than humans two shows by Scott
buck so there you go bud buck stops here
cuz it's bad the thing is though it's
like you know the loyalty behind it all
it's like finally you've got an amazing
season they've redeemed themselves from
the first season man in films done okay
fine
well I mean know you like their show
they sort of shows have bad seasons
where it's like you know what they might
figure it out but they're their premiere
season was very bad so I get why no one
came back and that's fair
anyways it's fair that they cancel the
iron fist as well it wasn't exactly a
hit even with like a pretty good first
season but it is a big deal do you guys
think that this is a sign like a bad
sign good sign whatever for the
so the Marvel Netflix shows like Luke
Cage Jessica Jones daredevil I see so
because I think that what I mentioned
earlier right obviously that Disney's
not gonna let them do much more but then
also these shows are extremely expensive
to make I'm sure their pain and insane
licensing for you probably is my guest
to Marvel to order Disney so these and
all of the momentum that they had I mean
sorry Danny ran but you look at you
killed the momentum that all of those
shows I don't know that any of these
shows are pulling in what they used to
so it kind of is like yeah let's maybe
do let's wrap these all up is it my
guess is will Turner I'm really glad you
pulled sorry but I'm really glad you
pulled this photo too because it could
have been a cool scene but it was really
dumb he shot a bullet out of the air
with two bullets it's made no sense and
that's how the end in season 2 and I'm
like okay this is not gonna make it
anyway that just had daredevil and then
in each season would bring in a new
defender so it's like you know what they
state cause a daredevil did an amazing
job world building and then I think
Jessica Jones etc kind of focused more
on like the characters and like the you
know the hero slash villain and all that
torment I do wish you know we'd had
daredevil and then boom Jessica Jones
comes in maybe halfway through the
series and then Luke Cage comes in and
then it actually turns into the
defenders but then first season
daredevil normal they got season 2
daredevil you get Jessica Jones to get
like Appy I do ok then Jessica Jones
gets her own show Luke Cage that's where
he comes in because that's important
it's a domino effect first season
defenders what was the big villain hand
who's they've enemy of the hand iron
fist iron fist gets an intro there in
his season he's in we fall to go
season two let me know if you guys are
if you guys are watching daredevil
season 3 let me know and hit us up on
Twitter do you guys even remember what
was goin winning Game of Thrones the
dragon was underneath the building and
it collapsed daredevil Elektra we're
still down there yeah
dragon we haven't heard gamer friends
like oh I think your question was
rhetorical you did your job
Maisie Williams who's the actress that
plays iStock on Game of Thrones
oh yeah oh yeah not right she gave an
interview on The Guardian recently and a
lot of the times we're talking about
things that are so tight-lipped and
can't say anything we're going to
actually pick apart everything she said
to see if she actually did something
that's what we did
cool so what she said was mmm this
season was quite a big one for me yeah
more to do mainly because there's just
less characters now and everyone's got
more to do so is this a spoiler there's
less people
sounds pretty most people dead the idea
that there's it's just that she has a
lot more to do is kind of like
interesting because it's like she
actually did play that little secret
assassin role yeah that season so if she
hasn't more to do than that like she
should go dear
maybe this her whole stories of
flash-forward so everyone's actually
dead she's 80 years old she's at the end
of the world story from Doctor Who so
nerdy thing the other people on her list
it's huge if you thought it was because
she says Circe's on her list direct like
completely
yeah you know you like the big theme
again Game of Thrones do you always see
like the chessboard or like them the
battle map with all the pieces putting
push into place we know where it's going
yeah right if she can die and the boy
decapitate you know a hole yeah but
that's not the biggest threat in mama
and the second thing that she said was
that the final scene and the shot was
beautiful she said I ended on the
perfect scene I was alone
shaaka is always bloody alone alright
spoiler that she ends alone yeah
weld in George RR Martin's say in some
interview a long time ago he's like I
always pictured Aria there at the end so
like that's kind of his vision I was
really good she's going through it all
and she's I had that pitch a long time
ago and I don't know if I still stand by
it but I think it'd be fun if we
actually see Aria sail west of Westeros
I just wondered like what goes that way
and she's gonna essentially find a tribe
of indigenous people and named the land
America pirate America it's the last
scene of the character or the actress
they might have that might have been the
first thing we see her in at the start
of the season they don't lastly I think
she had the blood in her shoes what if
she was dying alone which is also like
really tragic right like I don't want to
spoil other shows that I'm thinking of
but like sometimes a character just like
dies alone because no one's around and
they just fade away right yeah if a
person dies alone in the forest did they
ever live hmm yeah cuz how they get
there what did you do death has no
witness than the death never happy it's
still illegal that's what I told the
cops using the information that she's
given and that's what we're doing with
it that's predictions for the season she
dude I learned that dad if I want to
know the dragons and she died inside
when the belly is like Jonah in the
Bible mine is that she gives smallpox to
Native Americans mine doesn't sad and
then we sent the prisoners to another
island
or west well I think we nailed it yes we
confirm it honestly we are we are
squeezing nothing out of nothing but
we're not giving us anything else we'll
take any way we can get you try to get
your cardio in dormant I have a dormant
life don't worry in other news buckle up
kids because Gardens the galaxy vol 3
announced a working title of hot
Christmas and pushed the production date
back to 2021 oh my god you know you have
hot Christmases Joker movies so goofy
they look pretty silly but I'm so sick
of clown picture not the season was a
clown before the costume want the the
Joker to be a psychopath who loses mine
decides to dress up as a clown and he's
a family-friendly character than all
kids dress up as that's the character we
like doesn't it look like there's a
smaller Joker who's giant mannequin its
doormat puppeteering found it
continuing over sorry
WB may be developing a Superman TV show
starring Tyler hoechlin who plays
Superman you say clean I did learn a
name uh-huh
you put the hell in the game can we cut
the cam hoechlin play Superman Supergirl
and and he's gonna be showing up in the
big arrowverse crossover episodes this
year even was teased with a black
costume which is really cool but a lot
of people are talking about this could
be a backdoor pilot for a show about his
Superman also a lot of people who've
been teasing that that that crossover is
also back to a pilot for Batwoman so if
they make more shows I can't take it
yeah last but not least Michael Douglas
a K Hank Henry to him said in an
interview that the quantum realm will be
integral to Avengers 4 ain't that fun
case to grow in a way like membered into
the microphone so you could have said
either way we don't really know yeah
because I didn't know which one I saw
hyper cut from a man and the wasp of
everyone saying quantum and I'm not
actually kind of done with that word it
actually doesn't sound like a word
anymore but not quantum word it means
nothing
legitimately we have a good video on on
the quantum realms potential importance
in Avengers 4 so let's share that so
much there it is Oh Oh check it out dude
we've done it's been a rainy week we've
done all kinds of like fun but I feel
like it's been one on one of my favorite
weeks for videos so this channel it's
but all kinds of weird speculative stuff
but I feel like one of them's gonna be
right yeah all right
one of them's gotta be right where was
riot for six months watch the cars one
about religion
integral integral to shoes okay guys we
have finally arrived to some questions
that you guys were so nice to sham and I
put them in my pocket here and I'm gonna
fire them at my co-host it's because of
lightning around they got an answer
without hesitation and you'll be fast
we're gonna move everyone ready whoo
okay here we go Sam at Jared ransom Oh
No
what's a No what is the what is an
obscure Marvel character or team that
you think could be successful if given a
solo treatment in the MCU great Eric at
Quinton - Clark wants to know would you
rather be Darth Maul or the night king
Darth mom yeah ma at Putin s monster
wants to know if Henry is out as
Superman who should replace him Henry
Cavill really liked the look of her
tchen that's good for me Hado potato
wants to know which horror movie villain
do you think would have the highest
chance of would you have the highest
chance of survival against horror movie
Oh probably uh probably it follows
because be hard 16 wants to know will we
ever see
spider-ham in the MCU no I'm still
holding up Howard the Duck yeah Sam at
what a broad wants to know which x-men
character could you have helped prevent
Oh which x-men character could have
helped prevent thanasis snap if they had
been available Seifer he would have used
his power of translation garbage to
figure out how to talk to finish the
right way talk your way out of problems
kids don't punch your way out of these
Google Translate mod at Sunday duck
wants to know what was your first fandom
I will confess oh nice lightning round
shoe but I had Legolas and Anakin I had
them all over my ceiling is it I thought
you was Thomas
a transformer
I had Starscream that's my first toy Wow
now that I remember it's amazing
eclectic bunch for me at joke men wants
to know what is one thing you love about
fanboy culture and one thing you'd like
to change okay okay don't get too mean
one thing I love about it is I love
organized positivity about things I
think because there's so much cynicism
and so much negativity on the Internet
I like it when people are positive and
there are I think at least fanboy ISM
started as a way to express affection
and love for something when they'd like
to change about it is the over
protectionism in a sumption that you
know more about what the right way to
adapt a property is then the people who
created it and people could change that
Phillip that be Aquaman wants to know
what is your favorite cereal Jeffery
Carter Watson over mud if you lived in
Westeros what would your house sigil be
yeah Matt Carissa main wants to know one
have you seen a star is born - did you
cry as hard as you did when Spiderman
got dusted I didn't cry it out of those
scenes but I did tear up a lot when Sam
Elliott teared up oh that one hurt me
bad
you might even cry at the end stars born
know a doctor HP wants to know what was
your favorite toy when you were a kid
yeah I just answered in my last question
hey
and Philip at truce corn what's done
what is your dream project
oh my life that I want to make as a TV
show - volcano where you put the
chemicals in it you mean just like a
science fair project they make clothes
on it and mod your paper project I'm
doing it I start next weekend I'm doing
fundin season - should we talk about
that in our 15 second shout-out this 15
seconds of shadow rants about anything
you want my god oh my god moderators bad
guys finding the flag in season 2 we've
done season 1 is gonna be a little bit
different
Sam so I'm gonna get drunk and puke in
the bathrooms just outside throwing
shade but it's going to be a lot of fun
I've just bought a lot of props and
we've got two new panelists that haven't
been announced yet so I'll tell you what
does this go up today tomorrow I'll tell
you guys first Hector Navarro hey you
may have seen on Nerdist in geek and
sundry and also Rob Kazinsky who is an
actor and he's been in a bunch of stuff
including Warcraft yeah there you go Sam
you're gonna be doing them yeah they're
much more impressive than I am and very
good at this game yes
Sam's a voice of Sam take a break what's
your mine is um actually I haven't even
seen it but I still want you guys to see
the haunting of Hill House that show
whatever it's called it's getting great
reviews
I'm kinda like Eric where it's like I
only have so many things to watch but
I'm obsessed with horror - so if you
guys watching you want me to watch it
just hit me up on Twitter at fimo and
let me know but I'm plugging it because
I heard it's great yeah it's nothing
like the book interesting although
reading the book better because it's a
horror writer and she's female it was
written in the mid 50s and it's quite
impressive I just started listening the
last podcast on the left its I'm sure so
it's a very popular podcast where it's
like the three very funny dudes go into
like the the occult and conspiracy
theories in serial killers and it's just
like dark fringe level stuff and
it's really funny and I'm a big fan and
the most popular so it's probably the
one on the devil in the White City homes
and yeah it's it's fascinating stuff and
it's very fun and it's given us a lot of
ideas for future projects I mean we
might want to work on here but but yeah
Sam all right 15 seconds I'm doing three
really quick he'll that's a new series
on Netflix based on the graphic novel
it's the sweetest thing I've ever seen
it makes my heart feel good too
there is a podcast I'm listening to from
Ben Schwartz it's called the wine down
they talk with wine experts and then
comedians learned very little about wine
but I just want to hear people tell
jokes and third goals vote vote vote is
the most important thing here yeah with
the good messages today let's move on to
our trivia answer Sam's gonna vote so
you need to kill us just to uh let's see
I'm always bad I equal powers music mind
and then you take okay so here's a you
know we have the gift of shame and if
you get the question wrong estás decided
by our judges
you got to pick the one challenge left I
gotta put more challenges in there and
then they have to do it on screen to
make a big fool of yourself as you
become an animated gif now if it's gonna
be me okay so just remind everyone what
the question was in spider-man's first
appearance in 1962 he uses his newfound
abilities to win $100 by fighting a
wrestler what is a wrestlers name so
let's go down the line three
Nimmo rope Bonecrusher sam basher wrote
dug I just my head every time just
kidding no matter what I say how are you
doing mark Cobra that's fine okay things
that it's bone saw
so I'm thinking now cuz you two had burn
in it that it's the first things we
think bone saw was the one in the movie
in in 2002 but in the classic Bob no-win
like spider-man wears the hoodie and
yeah he's like yeah yeah the correct
answer is crusher Hogan crusher Hogan
Wow so all of us it's a season to do
there's no way I'm losing this which one
sounds cooler though one swing on
crusher dagger King Cobra Sam you gave
up when you wrote dawg did you see I
wrote it the same person it's got that
King Doug King Douglas Cobra all right
so judges said that Sam's yeah I'm
getting a point knocking words all right
so all right so we're gonna go shame it
chant doctor my task you're a zombie and
you're pulling out your own brains and
eating them oh great and then Sam will
go ahead and do his zombie brain thing
that Sam likes to do Dubai's I thank you
guys so much for watching this week's
episode of new rock stars news I want to
thank our host
Sam brains basher let's give them a
second to really just commit to this
without like it's going so slow
where are you brain Shan Shan oh there's
the train oh he's gonna hate it don't
you eat that be a boss and thank you to
Maude Garrett at Maude Garrett check out
pungent so it's gonna be on geek ball it
is yes - geek bombsite it because I had
well it's some sliding because I had one
hundred nine thousand one hundred
thousand hundred nine thousand and now
I've got 99
broker Playboy videos first
comment down below about anything we
talked about
hey if you had a better idea for what we
should have covered this week go ahead
and comment it down below I'm still
going when to say when
yeah he pulled his brains out tweet at
new rock stars it just if you have some
feedback which I think you might like
this video and share it around and
subscribe to this channel I'm literally
just getting a phone call we do deep
dives of what you love Anke the common
truth is my friend named dong o
nearly dug by everyone's guys we'll see
you next week Sam say goodbye costume
contest man that egg that ending was
just dug it wasn't
[Music]